thank you very much Frank Kathy deeply
grateful to the Hewlett
supported this meeting and this year
long project and to Frank Moretti
Maurice matey's and others at this
extraordinary Center here at Columbia
whose wisdom whose work with the magic
of new media and education is just so
exciting as you'll see over these next
two days and to all of our participants
who have come to visit with us this week
last week a number of things happen that
bears some relevance to the state of
affairs that this conference is meant to
address in Daily Variety the show
business Bible there was another
handsome article about an accomplished
company active in the documentary field
Atlas media the article went one of the
most active producers of nonfiction
programming for a dozen cable networks
has set up a new division to develop and
produce theatrical documentaries that's
promising enough the article went on the
first feature-length project put
together with voom HD networks will
focus on a behind-the-scenes look at
meatloaf as he goes about prepping for
an 18-month worldwide tour this is at a
time when the learning channel The
Learning Channel originally conceived of
by founder John Hendricks is such
promise is now officially called TLC and
discoveries branding Bible and showcases
programs like what not to wear and Miami
Ink a show about tattoos when the news
doesn't tell us anything about the world
we live in or what we are doing in it
and when the US military our own
government has effective last we cut off
the access of all of our soldiers in
Iraq to myspace YouTube photobucket and
MTV calm a move redolent less of a
secretary of defense named gates than a
general secretary named Gomulka in a
closed society from a land at a time far
far away imagine for a minute a world
instead we're all of us in this room and
the organizations that large and small
we represent our stakeholders in the
future of nonfiction where faculty
librarians archivists curators
are passionately on the same side as
leading producers directors and
distributors and the millions of
consumers out there hungry for education
and for American and world culture then
we're video is as easy to create and
distribute and annotate and repurpose as
a piece of email is today imagine a
world where university education and
some of the projects you will hear about
this morning can connect to the outside
world at various levels for intelligent
contributions recognizing that the
thousands of Columbia faculty students
alumni and friends out there
notwithstanding the thousands of MIT
Yale UC Berkeley Case Western Michigan
State faculty students alumni and
friends out there notwithstanding even
the thousands of Cornell faculty
students alumni and friends out there
notwithstanding there are by any kind
calculation more smart people outside
the university walls and university
firewalls than inside of them and
imagine a world where the paths between
academic media productions archival
resources worldwide the talents and
experiences of producers directors and
cinematographers and the public are
paved swept and illuminated like runways
at an airport in the morning this is the
world we are going to be investigating
in some detail over these next two days
with presentations from stakeholders
from non-commercial institutions and
private enterprises and government
agencies concerned with its improvement
describing a set of common concerns
common obstacles and emerging solutions
for improving the field of educational
video that feel less than a hundred
years old whose systems are not yet in
tranche like the worlds of print and
whose future we can influence for the
better
so I would like to open with five
general points about today's media and
technology environment and say a couple
words about the structure of our meeting
to my five points first demand for
online video worldwide has exploded over
100 million videos are watched on
youtube alone every day the top 10 video
streaming sites now stream some 7
billion videos a month that's 10 million
Amina and bittorrent the internet
protocol that facilitates online sharing
and distribution of video and audio is
the number one file format in use on the
Internet worldwide these aren't just
people filming David Hasselhoff
thundering or swinging their house cats
around by the tail they are accessing
university lectures information and
resources that can in fact make us feel
proud and all things being equal safe to
be their neighbors second the
opportunities to produce video have
exploded teenagers groups of all ages
but teenagers especially or producing
and posting rich media online in numbers
that are growing exponentially over
70,000 videos go up on youtube every day
for example young people in the United
States and worldwide mimicking what we
do when we cut and paste casual text
from a website or an email or Word
document now believe they have a
veritable video access mandate a new
almost inalienable right to work with
video to access it cut it and paste it
change it post it much as with text
online my colleagues Mark Phillips India
and Jonah bossa wits have rift on the
fact that last year Stanford Law
Professor and creative commons founder
Larry Lessig never shy one about
identifying a trend declared
spectacularly after a presentation that
featured several video mashups from
young producers that text text is dead
that the written word has become the
latin of our modern times that the
ordinary language the vulgar or burnett
language the new language of the street
is video and sound and that the software
suites that facilitate video and sound
editing apples iMovie Adobe's premiere
the others listed here including open
source video editing tools as well are
the new essential tools of speech in the
digital age what less it calls a shift
in production and use patterns from
read-only to read/write engagements with
video now result in millions of original
new videos and mashups of classic
material being posted online every week
according to one estimate almost half of
all video online today's user-generated
that's a remarkable statistic Walt
Mossberg of the Wall Street Journal has
a pine that everyone now can be a video
producer and he tells us the most every
computer package on a Mac or Windows now
comes with elemental video editing
software in the camera and we can buy
additional software for a few hundred
dollars the Financial Times is declared
with a looming of YouTube from whom ovid
i Greenberg will speak to us today and
with the arrival of juste the new video
service from the founders of skype and
cos ah who's director of business
development will speak to us today that
the democratization of video
distribution is now underway their
access and this is the third point is
undeniable first two professional
resources moving image archives millions
of hours of audio and video around the
world and we will hear from several of
these curators of these archives today
and then to everything
as you can see from this slide over the
next 13 years an ipod for a device its
size will be able to hold a year's worth
of video by 2012 all the commercial
music ever created by 2015 and all the
content ever created in all media by
2020 shrek three is already online today
and by the time my youngest child
Charlie who is six enrolls at Columbia
an iPod or a device its size would be
able to hold all the human knowledge
ever created in all media whatever that
device is you can bet that will have a
camera and a microphone on top of it so
my fifth and final point is that the
legal and economic constructs around all
of this are changing too but my
colleague Eric notice at the center told
me yesterday that chris anderson's new
book contract at hyperion from the chris
anderson from the long tail the editor
wire is for a volume called free to be
delivered in 2008 and on his blog chris
is asking people which subtitle they
like better free the story of a radical
price 0free how 000 changed the world
free how companies get rich by charging
nothing free the economics of abundance
and the marketplace without money free
the past and future of a radical price I
kind of like five he says what do you
think we will hear from Eric Saltzman at
Creative Commons Josh Nathan general
counsel at wnet 13 and others here on
both days about new initiatives in this
area and legal regimes emerging to cover
education and public use more generally
all of this suggests that it is time now
to take the temperature of rich medium
now at the start at the heart of this
meeting is the University and its work
at the intersection of video education
and open culture on any given day at the
center my colleagues here will be
transcoding classic silent films for a
class in the school of the arts
perfecting a video editing tool to allow
the comprehensive
population of moving images for
assignments working in the school of
social work with archival video from the
Cambodian killing fields filming new
assets in a mock AIDS intervention
digitizing an interview with an English
professor about Ralph Ellison shooting
b-roll of the Apollo Theater and the
churches and synagogues in Harlem video
recording teachers teaching children
account at Teachers College for judging
documentaries for the DuPont awards at
the same University that also
administers the pulitzer prizes and the
Bancroft prizes in history that energy
is huge but at the same time the
particular suite of challenges that
universities and other educational
institutions face in the digital video
age requires some new and profound
examination and will benefit from
ongoing proofs and descriptions of best
practices being compiled published and
consistently improved and updated so
this meeting teaches 45 speakers over
two days Maurice and his team have
provided us opportunities to enter
comments about the presentations online
in case we don't have time to razz our
speakers while they're up here at the
podium and and please take advantage of
this those of you who care to with your
laptop's we are fortunate to have the
greatest speakers working on these
topics beginning to address their
experiences here with us their
challenges in the following fields
University productions educational
productions outside the Academy
distribution options and best practices
for educational video rights and key
legal considerations for producers
distributors and consumers technology
issues at the intersection of video and
education archiving preservation best
practices archiving access best
practices teaching and learning best
practices at the heart of the heart the
heart of this meeting research and
scholarly communication best practices
and finance best practices towards
sustainability and self-sustainability
when the people who are represented in
this room educators and public
castors public broadcaster's and public
libraries work closely together when
cultural institutions and of private
enterprises can fashion useful
agreements / cultural heritage materials
stimulated by educators educators like
Frank Moretti with a nudge from an
occasional mediator like Jeff you boys
we can see some great things happen
here's a clip meant to demonstrate just
a bit of that it's from an interview
that we recorded at USC late last year
for project that we are doing front of
harvest hundreds of hours of film about
Alzheimer's it's directed by a Columbia
DuPont award-winning filmmaker it's shot
by a Sundance award-winning
cinematographer and this is Roberto Diaz
Bobby Brenton professor of molecular
pharmacology and toxicology at USC
director of the star science education
program there and head of the
pharmaceutical Sciences Center the video
of a neuron and you begin to see a
neuron that looks beautiful it's healthy
it's plump it has these beautiful arbors
and neural connections and it's
connected even in a cell culture neurons
want to talk to each other they want to
connect they want to create those neural
circuits that say we can do amazing
things together we can make videos we
can find ways to prevent Alzheimer's
disease we can do this and then you
begin to see what happens when you put
just one of the degenerative insults of
Alzheimer's disease this beta-amyloid
peptide and you begin to see
at first the network begins to
degenerate I know the processes begin to
grow old before your very eyes and then
they shrink the cell body completely
implodes and now begins its transforming
reality of dying and dying in a way that
won't create more havoc by its dying
it's an implosion and then you begin to
see the results of not only that dying
that cell dying but the other cells in
the network progressing and dying so
that when one of them dies that one
neuron dying is a message and that in
other components of the neural network
begin to generate the network begins to
die
and with it who we are hopefully that
won't happen any of us during this
meeting try to keep it stimulating
enough and with that like to thank you
again for coming and maybe we can invite
our next panel up